let's just do it because our brain
thoughts are starting get antsy and the
top goodness out of this idea in
negative ways which is what this video
is all about
no I mean is very self oh wow sking
nailing it hi my name is very salty we
do no no no you know your life is
different now this has been a weird year
for me
this also is probably gonna be a very
rambling a little all over the place
video and that's it so you can accept
that or buy I want to sit down and just
sort of talk openly stream of conscious
esque style about the year I've had
because it's been wonky to say the least
there's been really wonderful beautiful
moments and this is the time of the
morning when goose decides to bark
because she's just been sleeping the
whole time that had the camera off but
when the camera goes on now it's a child
mother like dog - that's a really
wonderful moments this year are some
really beautiful joyous things and then
I've had some really dark and sad and
frustrating things this year it's just
been uh I guess a transitional year so
they wanted to sit down and talk about
it with you guys because I think that's
also what people do that helps is they
talk about it not necessarily on camera
I mean like I'm the therapist knows all
this but like you know she doesn't hit
like like and subscribe after a session
that would be fascinating and probably
unhealthy I wanted to talk about with
you guys because there has been a little
disconnect because I felt disconnected
from the internet all year and I wanted
to just feel a little bit more like a
human to you guys rather than so
presentational about cooking or you know
favorites videos their daugther nonsense
everyone I feel nervous saying all of
this stuff I think it's because I don't
put a lot of like my personal thoughts
and feelings out in such a direct way
but I think this is something a lot of
crazy
go through and a lot of people that
aren't creators go through it is the
idea of feeling stuck a feeling in a rut
of developing a lot of negative
self-talk that stifles your creativity
stifles your ability to have meaningful
relationships stifles your ability to
just go to a grocery store and buy
groceries sometimes for those of you I'm
watching me forever know that I've done
with eating disorder I've dealt with
anxiety depression and anxiety
depression have gotten a big hold of me
this year which is crazy because I'm in
like the most wonderful relationship
ever
but then my creative world feels very
overwhelmed with a lot of anxiety and
negative self-talk this year which has
kept me from creative kind of talked
about this last year a little bit and I
think I thought by talking about it it
might help facilitate some sort of
motivation and you know what that didn't
happen and I have finally come to terms
with the fact that you can't just go to
bed and like hope that the next morning
all the sudden you wake up and all the
lightbulbs are turned on and you're
ready to go and yeah you're back in the
strides that you used to have I've
gotten into a big rut of comparing
myself to my former self of going oh man
two-thousand twelve to fourteen fifteen
work the prime years and I could just
get back to what that felt like
then we'd be back on track baby turns
out that doesn't happen or work or is
good
it's very akin to when like retired
football players just drink heavily and
re-watch their old games to just feel
like they were once good at something
much like that and that's sad and dark
and depressive but it's kind of true
gotten myself into this hamster wheel
routine this year of comparing myself to
previous times and feeling like I'm not
living up to that level and talking
myself down from things out of things
that I'm not good
enough through things that like the
funny thing that I had going is gone
like that was a fluke and like all of
these irrational things that have made
me feel very weighed down it's like I
tied a bunch of bricks onto my feet and
I'm still going but I can swim across
that River watch this nope no I can't
I couldn't even swim across that River
if I didn't have any bricks on I'm not a
good swimmer helbig's are not a swimming
family when I was younger I did like two
small triathlons with my younger brother
and my dad in like our home town and we
are all three almost drowned and the
swimming was the first part of the
entire triathlon we made the teenage
lifeguards very nervous the cool thing
is I've been going to therapy
consistently which highly recommend if
you can do it very cool that's huge for
me because I don't like talking to
people about with feelings especially -
I don't like going back week after week
I like to do it once and go well I did
that scary thing that I didn't think I
could do and I have to do it again and
again and again and again to get the
results it's not just a one and done it
can't just fall asleep and wake up then
all the lights are on
okay and so I'm really proud of myself
for going and doing the therapy thing
it's been very helpful this is where I
go maybe I should have written down my
thoughts before I started this video to
try and make this a little bit more
cohesive but then when you say should to
yourself that's a negative way of
talking to yourself so I'm doing just
fine right now this is great it's all
gonna work out fine it is working out
fine we're in the present moment right
here I've really realized how much
negative self-talk I've given myself in
the last couple of months and it's
become this real heavy routine that I
feel like I finally am ready to
curiously investigate so to the end of
the year and as we get into the new year
everyone's doing their whole self
evaluations and figuring out what ways
they want to live their lives in 2020
also I think 2019 was a weird year for
all of us let me know if it was weird
for you so that I can feel not alone
here because I would love that
what am I getting at baby Oda was
exactly what I needed at the end of this
year
and I don't even care if the mandalorian
is getting boring I don't understand
plots of shows at all whatsoever anyway
I'm just waiting for that baby order to
show up oh there's got to be bars out
there that have BYOB why bring your own
baby oh that I don't know why I don't
know why you'd show up to a bar with
like a stuffed animal baby Yoda but I
don't know why you wouldn't either
I also it felt a little bit like I took
a step back last year and in that period
I really distanced myself from the
YouTube space almost in a way that when
someone takes a break in between high
school and college they take a year off
and then they try to go back to college
and everything is different and nothing
makes sense I mean to be fair even when
I was doing YouTube but really pounding
that YouTube space I didn't fully
understand what was going on and called
the platform I was just like here's a
new funny thing here's a new funny think
yours a new funny thing and they'd be
like how do you think we can make the
platform better like I don't even it's a
shock that I even know how to upload a
video so you're asking the wrong girl
and now it's like it's very intimidating
it's a very intimidating space now
because it's very different than what it
used to be I'm a little bit in a space
so I don't know what I want to do and I
feel very impatient about not knowing
and I want to just know and work and do
the next thing I have to give myself
some space to work on my brain house
this year faired for you guys anyone
else feeling similar things also I don't
know if you guys experienced like when
there's really great stuff happening in
your life there's a guilt for feeling
even slightly anxious or bad or negative
about other stuff in your life like but
this is so good and there's also a lot
people that would kill for this
situation so how could you even whine or
complain or cry about this situation I'm
allowed to feel all the feelings because
not a robot hey in the future I feel
like an AI robot is gonna rewatch that
clip out of context and they're gonna
come for me and murder me if they
haven't murdered our entire human race
already other thoughts I think about so
I have a hard time
bursting with gratitude I've heard em
expressing feelings especially on the
internet in the public forum I wanted to
say thank you to everyone that's been
watching the videos for years you guys
can tell if I'm off even if I try to
hide it and mask it y'all know you all
it's pretty transparent it's funny how
sometimes your most transparent when
you're trying to hide alive you probably
know this but I'm obsessed with Michael
Buckley because on his Instagram stories
he he's a life coach now he's oh gee
youtuber if you don't know then hello
welcome you probably a ninth grader and
my videos aren't for children so don't
copy me Michael Buckley is now a life
coach and his Instagram story is just so
wonderful to me I've been watching it
since the beginning of the year and he
bounced these like very wonderful seeds
of wisdom here and there and then he'll
show you about like his new sweater that
he got and how much he loves or hates it
and him at a piano bar and then him
talking about his adult soccer it's all
wonderful hodgepodge but the stuff that
he was saying even this morning it felt
very pointed and I got scared to even
sit down and do this video even after I
decided that I was going to then all the
negative talk is like hey guess well
over here we're ready to do our job
which is talk you out of it I watched
his Instagram story and it you just
talked about how comparing yourself to
your former self is so detrimental that
you are exactly where you need to be
right now and you decide how you show up
and everything is happening as it should
right now I only recommend for you guys
to go watch Michael Buckley story cuz
it's just so pleasant and I never know
what I'm gonna get and it's uh like you
said true delight I'm gonna talk about
audible in this episode because they've
sponsored this video and I'm thankful
for that
companies that I've been working with
this year that have sponsored videos
because one of their genuine companies
that I really love and I love working
with things that I can show you that I
actually use on a regular basis and -
they're probably the reason that I made
any videos this year if I didn't have an
obligation for an ad situation I
probably would have sat in blankets and
watch reality TV so I'm thankful that
they've even tried to support me enough
to get me motivated to make content this
year because I do like making content
once I get through all of the
for and why the [ __ ] are you doing this
it's really wonderful that audible
sponsoring this video because I just
start listening to yourself by Gary John
Bishop it's so perfect for the stuff
that's going on in my brain and world
right now I'm only thirty minutes into
it and I'm obsessed with it he's a
Scottish guy that is incredible it's
basically like tough love self-help it's
like if you have like an older Scottish
brother or dad that like loved you but
wasn't gonna coddle you like and that's
exactly the kind of self-help stuff that
I respond to it's like no [ __ ] and
it's straight to the point he basically
says in the first 30 minutes I'm not
gonna teach you how to do mantras I'm
not gonna tell you to say that you're a
lion because you're not a fishin lion
and second of all you're not a [ __ ]
lion I did an air kick when I heard that
it's all about negative self-talk and
it's all about how we can approach that
I'm just so excited to listen to this
that it might take me a second to edit
this video because I might just fall
down a worm Hall of listening to the
rest of this if you want to give
yourself an audible membership now is
the time or gift inaudible membership
now is the time because you can get
inaudible membership for 53% off you can
choose three titles every month an
audiobook and two exclusive audible
originals you can listen on any device
anytime anywhere with the audible app
it's super easy and like I said right
now for a limited time you can get your
first 3 months for $6.95 per month 53
percent off the original price three
months $6.95 per month if you visit
audible.com slash grace or you text
raise to 500 - 500 obviously my
recommendation is I'm yourself by Gary
John Bishop if you really want some of
that like Scottish punch and Scottish
punch is just called like Scotch right
they have a billion categories so you
can choose from different books an
audible originals the self-help
categories obviously very popular right
now the end of 2019 into 2020 2020 is
gonna be a kick-ass year for so many
things I feel it in my bones which is
why I think I'm bold enough to sit down
and have this
kind of conversation with you something
I would never have done years ago I also
am getting what humans call older so I
am giving less I also want to be more of
a person to you and not so
presentational because that's more in
line with how I'm in my life right now
the great things that have happened this
year obviously mamrie and I have our
podcast this might get weird that you
can listen to every Wednesday which has
been so awesome with a patreon for it
that's been really great and we had a
lot of excitement going into 2020 making
that work and also not too deep it's
been really cool if you guys have
listened to that podcast you can tell
that I'm having more in-depth
conversations with humans that I'd never
thought I'd have chance to sit down and
talk to and so that's where my brain
does add a little bit more it's less
away from the gag jokes and more into
just like being a human and also maybe
I'll just cringe after editing this
video and throw all of my devices into
the nearest water source I don't want to
predict the future I want to live in the
present it's a gift I know I'm gonna
turn this camera off and have 10,000 or
articulate thoughts about what I wanted
to say but that's me thinking negatively
this went great I did great thank you
guys for listening to this very rambley
just sort of mental health update it's
been a wonky year but it feels nice
admitting that it's also very cool to
start making active choices to switch
the way that this current situation is I
hope you guys have had as best a year as
you could we're all doing it we did it
women we almost did it there's still
time for it to hit so many fans there is
so much time for people matter to hit
win sources if you liked this video
don't forget to subscribe especially if
you're my therapist again thanks guys I
don't know